the written word is the most important
invention
in human history but as long as humans
have had the ability to share
information
they've also had the need to conceal
that information as well
this need led to the invention of
cryptography
the word cryptography comes from the
greek meaning hidden writing
and some of the earliest forms of secret
writing come from ancient greece as well
herodotus the father of history as he is
known
described a way of hiding writing by
putting a message on a wooden board
and then covering it with a layer of wax
during greece's war with persia in the
5th century
bc this approach was used to send
military correspondents
this sort of concealment is known as
steganography
meaning covered writing it was common
all over the ancient world
from greece to china but as you can
probably guess
this approach has some issues the main
one being that if the message is
discovered its contents will be easily
revealed
this dilemma gave rise to cryptography
which doesn't hide the existence of a
message
but instead hides its meaning
cryptography can be broken down into two
subtypes transposition and substitution
transposition is when a document is
rearranged
creating an anagram and it is the
earlier form of cryptography
an early historical example is once
again from ancient greece
specifically the city-state of sparta
the spartans used a device called a sky
tale to hide their military
communications
it consisted of a strip of leather
wrapped around a wooden rod
the sender would write his message on
the leather as it was twirled around the
rod like so
when unfurled the message would seem
like a jumble of letters
but once the receiver wrapped the strip
around an identical rod of their own
the message would become clear
transposition has some major flaws
though
for one a short message has a limited
number of scramblings
for instance the word dog can only be
rearranged five ways
and larger messages while more difficult
to
disentangle for an interceptor will also
be
too difficult for the intended receiver
as well
because of this cryptography by way of
substitution was created
substitution rather than rearranging the
letters in a message
instead replaces the letters altogether
the most famous substitution cipher is
the
caesar cipher as the name implies it was
used by the roman dictator julius caesar
during the golic wars
in the 1st century ad the caesar
cipher also known as the caesar shift
cipher
replaces any given letter with the
letter three spaces down the alphabet
this is why it's called a shift cipher
because the cipher alphabet is simply
the plain alphabet
shifted three spaces like so
traditionally
caesar favored a shift of three but as
you can see
you can shift the alphabet as many times
as you want
accordingly there are 25 variations of
the caesar cipher
this is pretty good but if someone knew
you were using a caesar cipher to
encrypt your message
they could brute force their way through
by checking all 25
shifts but if you scramble the alphabet
at random instead of simply shifting it
over
you get 400 septillion that's 400
followed by 24
zeros different permutations so
obviously a wannabe code breaker would
have no chance brute forcing his way
through such an encryption
however a totally random arrangement of
the alphabet would also be difficult for
the receiver of a message to remember
one solution to this problem is a
keyword cipher
essentially the sender and receiver of a
secret message
would agree on a keyword and that would
be used to construct the cipher alphabet
let's say our keyword is shift easy
enough to remember right
so the cipher alphabet would be made by
spelling
shift then filling in the alphabet
according to the last letter of the word
in this case t like this
throughout the rest of the roman
empire's history and into the 6th
century a.d
these simple ciphers broadly called
mono-alphabetic
substitution ciphers were used to great
success
that is until the 8th century when a
group of ingenious scholars
found a way to break through these
puzzles
in the middle east about a hundred years
after the death of the prophet muhammad
a new dynasty took power called the
abbasid caliphate
this new leadership heralded what is
called the islamic
golden age this time of prosperity and
peace was the perfect cradle
for an intellectual age islamic scholars
centered in the baghdad house of wisdom
collected works on astronomy
medicine alchemy music mathematics and
more
they also added their own knowledge to
the collections
during this time muslim theologians were
studying the quran and the hadiths
they wanted to know which revelations
came earlier in the quran
and which hadiths were genuine and which
were not
they did this by using new statistical
and linguistic techniques
chief among them was called frequency
analysis
scholars saw how often words were used
in the quran and the hadiths and this
investigation would
show whether the linguistic styles and
etymological idiosyncrasies of the
documents
were in line with muhammad's they also
used this analysis on individual letters
not just words and in doing so
discovered that
certain letters were more frequently
seen than others
the first scholar to realize this
frequency analysis could be used to
break ciphers
was a man named abu yousuf
yakub uh this guy
we'll just call him al kindy he was a
very
important philosopher who wrote hundreds
of works on
all sorts of subjects from mathematics
to music to medicine he also wrote a
treatise on cryptanalysis
the study of code breaking here's a
quote from his book
which concisely explains his ingenious
technique
to solve an encrypted message find a
different plain text of the same
language
long enough to fill one sheet or so and
then count the occurrences of each
letter
call the most frequently occurring
letter the
first the next most occurring the second
and so on then look at the ciphertext
and also classify its symbols find the
most occurring symbol and change it to
the first letter
the next most common symbol is changed
to the form of the second letter
and so on until we account for all the
symbols
of the cryptogram we want to solve
essentially
find the most occurring letter in a
cipher and assume it is the most
occurring letter
in the normal alphabet in english the
most common letter is e
followed by t and so on well the least
common
are q and z here's a handy chart as you
might be able to guess
this method can't be used
unconditionally
say you're deciphering a secret treatise
on
zebras xylophones and quails
you wouldn't expect to see these letters
z x and q
very frequently and that would probably
throw a wrench in your analysis
still an intelligent cryptanalyst can
break pretty much
any monoalphabetic substitution cipher
using frequency analysis
even when letters don't line up
perfectly with their statistical
likelihood
heading back west europe have been going
through the dark ages
while the dark ages is generally a term
i dislike
when it comes to cryptography it is
fitting
as medieval europe had little interest
in the subject
that was until the renaissance with the
outpouring of interest and study in the
arts and sciences during this time
the study of cryptography was
reinvigorated too
the political situation in europe was
also responsible for the renewed
interest in keeping communication
secret this was especially true in italy
which at the time was not a unified
country but a mishmash of small
kingdoms and city-states all constantly
bickering with each other
so because of this political intrigue
mixed with the leaps forward in
scholarship
cryptography became a burgeoning
industry by the 15th century
almost every court in europe had a
cipher office
and every ambassador a cipher secretary
but with the islamic code breaking
techniques
having been brought to the west the
cryptographers were still
at a disadvantage they needed new
innovations to trip up the cryptanalysts
the first was the introduction of nulls
nulls are symbols put into a cipher that
have
no meaning let's say you had a cipher
made from numbers
1 to 50. a quick side note
you may think that a cipher made from
symbols or numbers
instead of letters would be more
difficult to solve but they're not
frequency analysis works just fine
regardless of what images are used
ciphers using things other than letters
existed for centuries before this
i just hadn't mentioned them so a cipher
made from 1 to 50.
well seeing as there are only 26 letters
in the english alphabet
only about half of these numbers would
actually correspond to letters
the rest would be nulls the second
innovation was to simply
misspell the encrypted message so that
when a cryptanalyst tried to break the
cipher he would slowly uncover
misspelled words
and then stop thinking he's going about
it all wrong
and lastly the introduction of codes
in cryptography codes and ciphers are
two different things
codes are words that mean other words
like a code name codes replace words
while ciphers replace letters codes are
obviously most useful
when applied to a short message but
not so good with long messages because
of this limitation cryptographers
started using
nomenclatures nomenclatures are a mix
between
ciphers and codes essentially a message
would be encrypted
using a cipher while also using a small
list of
important code words as impressive as
all these new techniques were
a cunning and intelligent code breaker
could figure out the nulls
ignore them as spellings and understand
the code words through context
for decades cryptanalysts still had the
upper hand
as shown in the case of mary queen of
scots
while imprisoned on trumped-up charges
queen mary took part in the
babington plot a plan by english
catholics
to kill queen elizabeth and replace her
with mary
she had corresponded with the
conspirators
using a cipher which was unfortunately
broken by
english cryptanalysts proving queen mary
guilty
she was executed on february 8 1587
so clearly cryptographers needed a
better system
and in the 16th century a frenchman
named vigineri
would come up with it join us next time
as we continue to explore the history
of cryptography